AND NOW TO PLAY RT WITH COMMENT.
RT WITH COMMENT.
I AM SO EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
I GOT MORE EXCITED ABOUT THIS
THAN MOST PEOPLE.
THIS IS A FEATURE I WANTED FOR A
LONG TIME.
TWITTER LAUNCHED A FEATURE THAT
ALLOWS YOU TO EMBED AND COMMENT
RIGHT WHEN THEY HIT RETWEET.
SO YOU'RE NOT RETWEETING, YOU
CAN RETWEET WITH A COMMENT.
I GET EXCITED ABOUT THE WEIRDEST
THINGS.
IT IS EASIER TO RESPOND
SARCASTICALLY TO STRANGE AND
ANNOYING TWEETS.
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU SOME WEIRDO
TWEETS, AND FOR 250 POINTS, I
I WANT YOU TO GIVE ME YOUR
REWTWEET COMMENT ALONG WITH
THAT TWEET.
FIRST ONE DOES ANYONE ELSE THE
TOP OF THE KEY LOOKS LIKE A
PENIS. #FINAL4
#NCAACHAMPIONSHIP.
JESSIMAE.
>> EVERYTHING LOOKS LIKE A PENIS
WHEN YOU ARE SINGLE AND LONELY.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> YEAH.
>> AH!
>> Chris: NEXT ONE IS
DISTURBING MY MOM WROTE LAST
NIGHT BECAUSE SHE GOT A BUNCH OF
NEW FOLLOWERS ON TWITTER.
OH, GOD -- MY VAGINA HURTS.
GAVE BIRTH TO 200 MORE KIDS
OVERNIGHT.
HASHTAG LOVE MY TWEET.
NOW I KNOW HOW MY MOM FEELS
WHEN I SAY HORRIBLE FILTHY
THINGS ON STAGE.
I FEEL REAL ICKY ABOUT IT.
BUT IF YOU RETWEET THAT IN A
COMMENT WHAT WOULD YOU WRITE?
>> THIS WOULDN'T BE A PROBLEM IF
YOU WERE OPEN TO MORE BUTT
STUFF.
>> Chris: IT IS MY MOM! STOP IT!
OH, POINTS.
ANDREW.
>>PLEASE HAVE ME BACK.
>> YOU SEE, MOM, AT NERDIST MOM
KEEPS HER FOLLOWERS INSIDE OF
HER VAGINA.
>> Chris: NO.
THAT IS NOT WHAT SHE IS SAYING,
ANDREW.
>> HASHTAG COME HOME TO DAD.
>> Chris: POINTS.